well there's a bunch of businesses that
come out of the industry and i think
we're going to see more and more go
public so let's say that that number
doubles or triples of like the publicly
traded companies that come out of the
bitcoin and crypto industry because
you're just going to get a bunch of
startups that continue to grow and
eventually go public whether it's direct
listings ipos or spax that number will
just grow and i think there's a dozen
other companies that are public that are
holding it in their treasury at a a
smaller amount so what did the catalyst
i mean clearly one thing that's already
happening right is the regulatory
clarity that's coming the more clarity
if the regulators uh move forward and
they clarify the treatment of uh stable
coins and security tokens and defy
exchanges
i you know i feel like the ca
the connection of bitcoin to crypto
has been holding it back
right because because stable coin
regulation is unclear secure many
cryptos are security tokens that's uh
that's holding us back the exchanges
that are trading bitcoin while they're
trading security tokens right the
connection of bitcoin to ship or
dogecoin
right this this holds back um
a public entity from wanting to get into
that space i mean in fact it's it's
really
the express concern that the sec has
about uh approving a bitcoin spot etf
right which is they're concerned about
the markets
where uh bitcoin is trading right and
they're concerned probably about
what's what's bitcoin volatility coming
from it's coming from the cross
collateralization of of crypto markets
with high leverage trading it off hours
right against thin liquidity pools of
other security tokens
right and so
as to ask that clarity comes with regard
to the entire crypto ecosystem
it's it's going uh to decrease
volatility and it's going to increase
confidence of large public investors and
large public companies that'll be part i
think as if we get clarity from fasbi
or or any kind of improvement in the
accounting situation
uh that's a that's a plus and there's i
mean there's a groundswell of interest
right there are 515 letters sent to
fasbee on this subject and
and there was a lot of commentary from
regulators from you know we've got
congressmen we've got senators
we've got uh auditors we've got big
institutional investors we've got big
publicly traded companies and they're
all opinining on the issue so and i have
yet to see anybody i haven't seen any
articulation by anyone suggesting that
the current accounting treatment
is beneficial yeah
so it's it's it's broad-based consensus
that it's time to take a look at this
again so i think that accounting is
important i think that you know we just
see the barriers with the banks getting
knocked down right
like at the point that
you saw the commentary by the chair of
the fdic
where she said we're looking for ways to
allow banks to hold bitcoin on their
balance sheets
right if uh if fd ic it used to be we
dreamed our dream was one day
big banks
may actually own bitcoin
you know what if all the big banks own
bitcoin but now i think we flipped to
the
to another observation and this is a
this is an interesting one
in that stable coin
working group
paper that was released last week
not only did they say it's okay for fdic
approved banks to hold stable coins they
actually said
it's required to be an fdic insured bank
to hold a stable coin okay so we're
we're actually growing up as a crypto
industry we're going from
unlicensed
non-institutional grade corporations
that are primarily entrepreneurial and
fast-moving
to licensed institutional
regulated entities
and uh
if you look at that isn't the conclusion
that the next step i see as a green
light jp morgan
citigroup bank of america are going to
issue a trillion dollars worth of stable
coins i mean it's an invitation like
it's a green light
to to every single
bank in the world right if you're if
you're silver gate or you know
anybody that's in the crypto industry
now
right this is this is kind of um
a message
i don't think it's that much longer
right
if
you can hold a stable coin as a digital
asset it's not that much longer behold
before you hold bitcoin as a digital
asset
and if if the fdic is saying
we need to find a way for banks to be
able to hold this
and if the president's working group is
saying you need to be a bank in order to
hold this the stable coin
then um i think that sometime in the
next 12 months
we actually start to see large uh banks
getting in the business is this good or
bad the like financialization of bitcoin
let's talk about and then there's
obviously all of these other
technologies and assets
but i think that there's a group that
would argue the more that the asset
becomes financialized the more that it
gets uh not just accepted by the
licensed organizations but you see
legislation or directives that say uh
you have to be fdic insured in order to
interface with this stuff uh they look
at that as negative there's other people
who look at it as a positive so how do
you think about the pros and cons of
what i'll just call like the
financialization of what were
assets that you know many people were
attracted to in the beginning because
they weren't part of uh the existing
system
bitcoin is decentralized and it's an
asset and it's already gone to 200
million places and you might not like
the people that own it right don't they
call it the money of enemies
yeah right the point is bitcoin's going
to people who have politics that you
disagree with
right
it's almost certain so it's spreading at
such a rate
it's like fire and it's like electricity
or mathematics and you can have an
opinion do you think it's good or bad
for banks to have mathematics
it's like we're the only ones with math
is it good or bad for people to be able
to read and write
it used to you know there was a concern
that we shouldn't let everybody read and
write it's just basic technology it's
spreading as fast as it can spread